guys right over the top of heart
[Applause]
bollocks ball inside finds McKeen leads
the team in dumps her miss he has had
three consecutive games where he has
just been lights out in the first
quarter he certainly has
[Applause]
his body to spin off the defense ghetto
way to the hole and Cody
brings it across the time line and lusty
loves up ball around
Kimbo tough chance for Cody can't handle
that hot pass second dunk of the quarter
for JaVale McGee what's going on only
follow tips yet to make one there's a
lot of alley-oop to this game ball finds
McGee
deep three
much like Jason Kidd riches
play McGuigan
Lonzo ball wolf tyson chandler back in
the game for the lakers all they want to
do is run
LeBron James gets ahead of everyone it
was past it
Bahai files bridges Emily clucks both
plates very well in the first half
[Applause]
got to the rapid transition dumps but
that one right there
good ball Haley splits the double-team
and throws it down to the two high
scores for the Hornets tonight Bob James
plays like he's the Friskies youngest
player on the floor